I guess T Rump has decided
to become a man of his word
at the worst possible time
this week.
I just thought he was saying
all that (bleep)
when he was trying
to get elected.
Then he was gonna be like,
"Ah, (bleep) it.
I'm just gonna coast
for four years."
I didn't know he was gonna go
into (bleep) turbo mode.
-(laughter) -So he made good on
his insane plan to ban Muslims
from entering the United States,
and literally everyone hates it.
Why, just look at this tweet
from 2015.
"Calls to ban Muslims
from entering the U.S. are
offensive and unconstitutional."
Oh, I wonder
if Trump's gonna come across
this libtard named, uh...
Mike Pence.
-Whatever.
-(laughter)
-Americans... Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
Doesn't even sound
like a real name.
Americans came out
by the thousands
to protest at airports
sending a message
that no ban will be tolerated,
and also, yes,
-travel can get worse. Uh...
-(laughter)
But nice job, everyone,
for rallying peacefully.
Even New York City cab drivers
joined in, showing solidarity
by refusing to take fares
to JFK during the protest.
Now it may pose
a temporary inconvenience,
but let me ask you something.
If you saw a scene in the movie
where a bunch of cab drivers
who normally don't give
any (bleep) about anything,
and you just saw, like,
all of their off-duty lights
flick on one-by-one
in protest in the city,
-you would bawl
your (bleep) eyes out. -♪
-Watch this.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
Come on!
Oh, my God.
Yes!
I'm telling you, you know,
you'd be at home alone,
and you'd be on a plane where...
I don't know why
I cry on planes as lot
for some reason
when I'm watching movies.
But like, we're like,
"There's still love
in this world!"
-Like, you would be so touched.
-(laughter)
The ban is so bad,
even thousand-year-old
robo villain Dick Cheney came
out against it. Take a look.
-(laughter) "Dick Cheney Thinks
Trump's Muslim Ban is
'Against Everything
We Stand for.'"
Guys, people got mad at Uber
for breaking the taxi strike,
started the hashtag
#DeleteUber.
And look. We actually found
that Dick Cheney joined
into that, too.
-Uh, here's...
-(laughter and groaning)
You can see up there.
It says, uh, "Do you want
to uninstall?"
(applause and cheering)
I do imagine that's like what
Steve Bannon's dick looks like.
-I know.
-(laughter and groaning)
That would make sense.
He is cold-blooded.
However, other apps
did take action
to show their opposition
to the Muslim ban
with Lyft pledging
to give a million dollars
-over four years to the ACLU,
Airbnb... -ARDEN MYRIN: Yes.
-Yes, absolutely.
-(applause and cheering)
Airbnb offering
to house refugees,
and Apple Maps pledging
to get Steve Bannon lost.
-Um...
-(laughter)
Comedians, how should other apps
make a political statement?
-Moshe Kasher. -Oh, actually
inspired by Airbnb.
Grindr's offering free holes
for refugees
to stick their dicks into.
-(laughter) -Yeah.
-HARDWICK: Okay. Oh, that's...
-Wow. -Yeah. It's really cool.
-(applause and cheering)
It's really...
-Yeah.
-Uh, on Tinder,
it is now positive
to swipe left,
but if you swipe right,
you can only date your daughter.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Okay. Points.
Points. Very layered.
Arden Myrin.
No matter
what address you put in,
Waze is gonna give you
the fastest route to Canada.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
All right. Yeah, points. -Yeah.
-Points.
-(applause and cheering)
You know, is the, uh...
I think we're all touched
by immigration in some way.
I think if anyone had wanted to
institute a ban on immigrants,
it should have been the
Native Americans in the 1600s.
(applause and cheering)
I mean, if we're really
being granular about it.
My mother's grandparents
came here from Italy.
They were not turned away.
They were welcomed.
I'm here, we are all touched
by immigration some way.
So I hope
that we find compassion,
and they we don't just go
on a crazy witch hunt
that isn't gonna work anyway!